anyways back to this death machine we
only have one button so you think that
button does just nothing yeah
we have one button
what does that do I just uh well it's
just like a cool design thing I don't
know
our partner came up with that he thinks
it looks cool that's the submarine
button yeah
what is this what is that there's a
button in the submarine
genius idea yeah makes customer feel
very comfortable you press that when you
see the Titanic yeah it turns green we
got it now we're gonna let you in a
little secret here this one doesn't
really do anything why why is that well
you know we want to add a little bit of
legitimacy so before we do that we just
kind of go up here and we go
everyone ready yeah yeah actually feel
better engage submarine mode
there we go we're in we did it